Okay. Let's get started again.
Um, so before I, uh,
proceed to Bayesian networks,
I'm gonna talk about a few announcements.
So as you probably know,
car is due tomorrow, um, p-progress is, uh,
due Thursday, um, and then finally the,
the kind of the big one, uh,
is the exam which is next Tuesday.
So everyone, if you're in the room or if you're watching from home,
please remember to go to the exam.
Um, um, the exam will cover all the material from the beginning
of the class up until and including today's lecture.
So all Bayesian networks, no logic.
Um, it doesn't mean you shouldn't use logic on the exam.
Uh, reviews are going to be in section,
uh, this Thursday and Saturday.
So you've got not one,
but two review sessions.
The first one we'll talk about, uh,
reflex and state-based models and the second we'll talk about variable risk models.
Um, at this point, all the alternative exams have been, uh, scheduled.
Um, if you can't make the exam for some reason,
then, uh, really please come talk to us right now.
Um, and just a final note is that the exam is,
uh, the problems are a little bit different than the homework problems.
They require more kind of problem-solving,
and the best way to prepare for the exam is to
really go through the old exams and get a sense for what kind of,
uh, uh, problems and questions you're gonna be asked. Question?
Where is the Saturday session?
Where is the Saturday session, does anyone know?
We don't know yet.
We don't know yet. It will be posted on Piazza.
Any other questions about anything?
I know this is, uh, a lot of stuff, um,
but this is probably going to be the busiest week,
and then you get Thanksgiving break. So that will be great.
Okay. So let's jump in.
So two lectures ago,
we started introducing Bayesian networks.
So Bayesian networks is a modeling paradigm where you define a set of variables,
which capture the state of the world,
and you specify dependencies depicted as directed edges between these variables,
and given the graph structure,
then you proceed to define distribution.
So first, you define
a co- local conditional distribution for every variable given the parents.
So for example, H given C and A and I given A,
and then you slam all these local conditional distributions, aka factors together,
and it defines a glorious joint distribution over all the random variables, okay?
And you think about the joint distribution as the source of all truth.
It is like a probabilistic database,
a guru or oracle that can be used to answer queries.
So this- in the last lecture,
we talked about algorithms for doing
probabilistic inference where you're given a Bayesian network,
which defines this glorious joint distribution,
and you're asked a number of questions,
and questions looked like this: Condition on some evidence,
which is a subset of the variables that you have observed,
what is the distribution over
some other subset of the variables which you didn't observe?
Then we look at a number of different algorithms in the last lecture.
There is the forward-backward algorithm,
which was useful for doing filtering and smoothing queries in HMMs,
this was an exact algorithm,
then we looked at particle filtering which happens, uh,
to be useful in a case where your state space,
the number of varia- uh, the values that a variable can take on,
it can be very large.
Um, and this is an approximate,
but in practice it tends to be a good approximation.
Um, and then finally, particle filtering which- sorry,
and Gibbs sampling, which is this much more general, uh,
framework for doing probabilistic inference in, um,
arbitrary, uh, factor graphs,
and this was again approximate, okay?
So so far, we've, uh, bit off two pieces of this,
uh, modeling inference learning triangle.
We've talked about models,
we've talked about inference algorithms,
and finally today we're gonna talk about learning.
And so the question in learning,
as we've seen repeatedly throughout this, uh,
course, is: Where do all the parameters come from?
So so far, we have assumed that someone just hands you this,
these local conditional distributions which,
uh, have numbers filled out.
But in the real world, where do you get these?
And we're gonna consider a setting where all of these parameters are
unknown and we have to figure out what they are from data, okay?
So the roadmap, we're gonna start- first start with supervised learning,
which is going to be the kind of the easiest, easiest case,
and then we're gonna move to unsupervised learning where some of the,
uh, variables are gonna be unobserved, okay?
Any questions before we dive in?
[NOISE] Okay.
Let's do it. So the problem of learning is as follows.
We're given training data and we want to turn this into parameters, okay?
So for the specific instance of, uh, Bayesian networks,
training data looks like an example is an assignment to all the variables, okay?
This will become clear in an example.
And the parameters are all those local conditional probabilities that
we now assume we don't know, okay?
So here's a question: Which is more computationally more expensive for Bayesian networks?
Um, is it probabilistic inference given,
uh, the parameters or learning the parameters given data?
Um, so how many of you- just use your intuition,
how many of you think it's the former,
probabilistic inference is more expensive?
Okay. One maybe.
How about how many of you think learning is more expensive?
Yeah. That's probably what you would think, right?
Because learning seems like there's just more unknowns,
um, and it can't- how can possibly it be, um, easier.
It turns out that it's actually the opposite. Yeah. So good job.
[LAUGHTER] Um, and, this will hopefully be a relief to many of you,
um, because, uh, I know probabilistic inference gets a little bit, uh,
quite intense sometimes and learning will actually be, um,
maybe not quite a walk in the park, but, uh,
it will be, um, uh,
a brisk stroll in the park.
Um, and then when we come back to unsupervised learning, it's gonna get hard again.
So, um, at least in the fully supervised setting,
it should be easy and intuitive.
So what I'm gonna do now is going to build up to
the general algorithm by a series of examples of increasingly complex Bayesian networks.
So here's the world's simplest Bayesian network.
It has one variable in it.
[NOISE] Let's assume that variable represents the rating of a movie.
So it takes on values 1 through 5.
And to specify the local conditional distribution,
you just have to specify the probability of 1,
the probability of 2, the probability of 3,
probability of 4, and probability of 5, okay?
So these five numbers represents the parameters of the Bayesian network, okay?
By fiddling these, I can get different distributions.
Okay. So suppose someone hands you this training data.
So it's fully observed, which means I
observed- one time I observed the value of R to be 1,
um, the second day I observed the value to be 3,
third day I observed it to be 4,
and so on, okay?
So this is your training data, okay?
So now the question is: How do you go from the training data
here to the parameters, okay?
Any ideas? Just use your gut, what does your gut say?
Count the number of [NOISE] and then divide them.
Yeah, count and then divide or normalize, okay?
So this seems a very natural intuition.
Um, later, I'll justify why this is a sensible thing to do.
But for now, let's just use your gut and see how far we can get.
Okay. So the intuition is that, um,
the probability of some value of r should be
proportional to the number of times it occurs in the training data.
So in this particular example,
I look at all the possible values of r 1 through 5 and I just see 1 shows up once,
2 shows up 0 times,
4 shows up 5 times, and so on.
So these are the counts of the particular values of r,
and then I simply normalize, okay?
So normalization means adding the counts together,
which gives you 10,
and dividing by 10,
which gives you actual probabilities, okay?
It's pretty easy, huh? Yeah? Good. Okay. So let's go to two variables.
So now you improve your model of, uh, ratings.
So now you take into account the genre.
So genre is a variable G which can take on two values,
drama or comedy, and the rating is the same variable as before.
And now let's draw the simple Bayesian network which has two variables, um,
and the local conditional distributions are P of G and P of R given G, okay?
So again, I'm gonna give you some training data which specif-
each training example specifies a full assignment to all the variables.
So in this case, it's d, 4,
d- and this one it's d,
4 again, uh, this one is c, 1 and so on.
And the parameters here are, uh,
the local conditional distributions,
which is P of G and P of R given G, okay?
Okay. So let's proceed to do this,
um, and here following our nose again.
Uh, we're going to estimate each local conditional distribution separately, okay?
So this is may not be obvious why separate- doing it separately is the right thing to do.
But trust me, it is the right thing to do and it certainly is the easy thing to do.
So let's, uh, just do that for now.
Okay. So again, loo- if we look at P of G,
so we have to look at only this data restricted
to G and we see that d shows up three times,
c shows up twice so I get these counts and I normalize,
and that's my estimate of the probability of G, okay?
And now let's look at the conditional distribution R given G. Again,
I'm going to count up the number of times that these variables,
uh, G and R show up.
So d, 4 shows up twice; d,
5 shows up once and so on;
count and normalize. Question?
So if, if instead of R given G had-
The probability R of r,
would that cause any differences in the results,
like, if the order [NOISE] were changing?
Yeah. That's a good question. So the question is,
what happens if we define our model in
the opposite direction where we have P of R and P of,
uh, uh, G given R?
So then you would be estimating different probabilities.
You would be estimating P of R,
which contains 1 through 5,
and then P of, uh,
G given R, which would be,
you know, a different table.
Do you get the same results?
Uh, so the question is,
If you do inference,
do you get the same results?
Um, in this case,
um, you will get the same results.
In general, you're not.
Uh, you're- depending on the,
the model you define,
you're actually gonna get a different, uh,
distribution, um, which will lead to different inference results.
Yeah. This happens when you have two variables and
you couple them together and you do things like this way.
You're effectively estimating from the space of
all joint distributions G and R. But if you have, uh,
conditional independence and you have, for example, HMM,
the order, how you write the model definitely affects what inferences can return.
Okay. All right.
So, so far, so good.
So now let's add another variable, okay?
So, uh, so now we have a variable A,
which represents whether a movie won an award or not.
Um, we're going to draw this Bayesian network,
um, and the joint distribution is P_G,
P_A, P_R given A and G, okay?
So this type of structure is called a V structure, uh,
for obvious reasons, and this remember was the thing that was tricky.
This is the thing that leads to explaining away and,
um, all sorts of tricky things in Bayesian networks.
It turns out that when you're doing learning in them,
um, it's actually the- all other trickery goes away.
Okay. So, um, let's just do,
uh, the same thing as before.
So we get this data.
Each data point, full assignment to all the variables.
So this is d, 0,
3 corresponds to G equals d and, um,
A equals 0, and R equals 3,
and the parameters are all again all the local conditional distributions.
Um, and now I'm gonna count and normalize.
So this part was the same as before, counts in, uh,
the genres, d shows up three times,
c shows up twice, normalize.
Um, A is treated very much the same way.
So, um, three movies have won no awards,
two movies have won one award.
So the probability of a movie winning award is 2 out of 5.
And then finally, um,
this is the local conditional distribution of R given G and A,
and here we have to specify for all combinations
of all the variables mentioned in that local conditional distribution.
I'm gonna count the number of times that configuration shows up.
Um, so d, 0, 1 shows up once right here; d,
0, 3 shows up once,
right here and so on, okay?
And now when you normalize,
you just have to be careful that you're normalizing only over the variable,
uh, that you're, uh,
the local distribution is on; in this case,
R. So for every possible unique setting of G and A,
I have a different distribution, okay?
So d, 0, that's a distribution over 1 and 3.
And if I normalize, I get half and a half and each of these other ones
are completely separate because they have different values of G and A.
Okay. Any questions?
All good? All right.
So that wasn't too bad.
Um, so now let's invert the V and look at this structure,
where now we have genre,
there's no award variable,
but instead we have two people rating a movie and the Bayesian network looks like this.
The genre and we have R_1 given G and R_2 given G. And for now,
I'm going to assume that these are different,
uh, local conditional distributions.
So we'll have PR_1 and P of R_2.
So notice that in this lecture,
I'm being very explicit about the local conditional distribution.
Here, I'm instead of just writing P of G,
which can be ambiguous,
I'm writing P of G to refer to the fact that this is the
local to conditional distribution for variable G. Um,
this one's the one for R_1,
this one for R_2, and those are different.
And you'll see later why this, uh, this matters.
Okay. So for now,
we're gonna go through the same motions.
Hopefully, this should be, um,
fairly, um, intuitive by now.
You simply count, normalize,
um, for the P of G and then for R_1,
I'm just going to look at the first, uh,
or the second element here which corresponds to R_1 and ignore R_2, right?
So G R_1. So d,
4 shows up twice.
So I have d, 4, uh, and d,
4 that shows up twice;
d, 5 shows up once,
that's the d, 5; c,
1 shows up once;
and c, 5 shows up once, okay?
And then normalize, get
my distribution, and then same for R_2.
Now ignoring R_1, I'm gonna look at how many times did G equals d and R_2 equals 3, okay?
So you can think about each of these as a kind of
a pattern that you sweep over the training set.
So, um, you have d,
5 so that's a 1 here; and d,
4 that's a 1 here; and d,
3 that's a 1 here and so on and so forth, okay?
And then you normalize, okay?
How many of you are following this?
Okay. Cool. All right.
So now things- um,
I'm gonna make things a little bit more interesting.
[NOISE] So here I've defined
different local conditional distributions for each rating variable R_1 and R_2, right?
But in general, maybe I have R_3, and R_4,
and R_5, and I have maybe a thousand people who are rating this movie.
I don't really want to have a separate var- distribution for each person.
So in this model,
I'm going to define a single distribution over rating conditioned on genre called PR,
and this is where subscripting with the actual identity of
the local conditional distribution becomes useful and this
allows us to distinguish PR from this case,
which is PR_1 and PR_2, okay?
Notice that the, the structure of the graph remains the same.
So you can't tell from just looking at the Bayesian network.
Um, you have to look at carefully at the parameterization.
Okay. So if I just have one PR,
what I'm going to do is,
um, what do you think the right thing should
to do with this if you're just following your nose?
[inaudible].
I'm sorry?
Yeah, so count both of them, I think is what you're saying.
So you combine them, right?
So, um, so P of G is the same,
and now I'm going- I only have one distribution I need to estimate, uh,
here r given g. Um,
and I'm gonna count the number of times in the data where I'm using- uh,
I have a particular value of g and a particular value of r. Okay?
And I'm going to look at both R_1 and R_2 now.
Okay? So D_3 shows up once here.
So that's, uh, R_2,
D_4 shows up three times.
So once here with R_1,
once here with R_1,
and once here with R_2, and so on.
I'm not gonna go through all the details,
and then you count and normalize.
Um, another way you can see this is that if I take the counts from,
um, um, these two tables,
I'm just kind of merging them,
adding them together, um, and then,
um, normalizing. Question? [BACKGROUND].
If the Rs are IID, are they drawn from the same conclusion, or?
Yeah, so is this assuming something about independence here?
Um, so here when I am doing- I am assuming the data points are independent first of all,
and moreover, I'm also assuming
the conditional independent structure of the Bayesian network is true.
So conditioned on g, R_1 and R_2 are independent.
[BACKGROUND]
Yes, so here I'm also assuming that R_1 given g has the same distribution as R_2 given g,
and this is part of the-when I define the model that way I'm,
you know, making that assumption.
[NOISE] Okay, so this is a general idea which I want to call out,
which is called, uh, parameter sharing.
Um, and parameter sharing is when
the local conditional distribution of different variables use the same parameters.
So the way to think about, uh,
parameter sharing is in terms of, uh, powering.
So you have this Bayesian network, it's hanging out here.
And behind the scenes,
the parameters are kind of driving it, right?
And you can think about the,
the parameters as these little tables sitting out there,
and you connect a table up to a variable if
you say this table is going to power, uh, this node.
Okay? So, uh, what parameter sharing in this particular example was saying,
this distribution of G powers this node and these two variables,
R_1 and R_2, are going to be powered by the same co-local conditional distribution.
Okay?
So, um, okay,
I'm gonna go to two [NOISE] more examples.
Maybe I'll draw them on the board to make this a little bit more clear.
So remember the naive based model,
uh, from, uh, two lectures ago.
So this is a model that has a variable that represents- adapted to,
uh, movie genre setting.
We have a genre variable which takes on var-values comedy and drama,
and then I have a movie review which represents
a document with L words in it and each word is,
um, drawn independently given, uh, y.
So I have said the joint probability is therefore going to
be probability of genre y times the probability of,
uh, w_j given y for all, uh,
words j from 1 to L. Okay?
So, so the way to think about this, um,
graph the Bayesian networks is,
um, you have a variable Y here,
and so I'm just gonna draw W_1, W_2, W_3,
and, um, I'm going to have
a local conditional distribution here which is y P genre of y.
So that's some table that's powering this node,
and then I have a separate one single other of variable, um, sorry,
local conditional distribution of, uh,
w, uh, y and w, and, um,
probability of what I call it word, word, um,
W given y, and
this distribution powers, um, these variables.
Okay? So notice that, um,
here there's two, uh, local conditional distributions,
we have genre and we have word,
even though there are l plus 1, uh,
variables in the Bayesian network. Yeah.
[BACKGROUND]
Yeah, so the input,
what are- so the question is what is the input to, uh,
P word W given y, uh,
so when you apply this to a particular variable, um,
in some sense you bind Y to Y and you bind W to a particular Wi at hand.
[BACKGROUND] [inaudible].
Exactly. And you can see this kind of mathematically,
where you hear we have,
um, you pass into the P word,
W j given y and j ranges from 1 to l. [BACKGROUND].
Okay. Um, just to kind of solidify understanding,
uh, let me ask the following question.
If, um, y can take on two values as in here and each word can take on,
um, d values, how many parameters are there?
In other words, how many numbers are in these,
uh, two tables on the board?
So shout out the answer [BACKGROUND]
to the [inaudible] right.
Okay, okay. So 2D plus 2,
so there's two here, right, so there's C_B.
So there's two numbers,
and then there are for every C,
there's d possible values, for d there're d possible values.
So there's 2 plus, uh,
so there's two here,
and then there's, uh,
d plus d here.
Okay? Now if you really want to
be fancy and count the number of parameters you really need,
it should be less and less because if I specify the probability of C, then you can, uh,
1 minus that probability is probability of D,
but let's not worry about that.
[BACKGROUND]
Okay, let's do the same thing for HMMs, um,
just to make sure we're on the same page here.
Since we all love HMMs, um, okay.
So in HMM, remember there is a sequence of hidden variables H_1, H_2, H_3.
Um, and for each hidden variable,
we have E_1, um,
E_2, and E_3 which are the observed variables.
And, um, there are three types of,
uh, distributions for HMMS.
There is, um, the probability of, um,
the- I'm gonna call it Pstart of h,
which is gonna specify with the initial distribution over H_1.
I'm gonna have the transition probabilities,
which I'm gonna denote,
um, h-, um, it's called h prime.
Probability of h prime.
Oh, I should write down Ptrans here.
H prime given h. So this is going to be
another distribution which powers each, uh, transition.
Uh, each non-initial hidden variable, okay.
Remember, the- these are pointing to variables, not edges or anything else.
And finally, I'm going to have, um, a distribution,
the emission distribution of e given h. Um,
that table is going to power, um,
each of the, uh,
observed variables e, okay.
And here, [NOISE] again, there are three types of distributions: start,
transition, and emission, even though there could be any number of,
uh, variables in a natural Bayesian network.
Okay. And just to be very clear about this,
when I apply this table to this node, H binds to,
um, H_1 and H_2- h prime binds to H_2.
And then when I apply it to this node,
H_2 binds to h and h prime binds to H_3.
And again, you can see this from, you know,
formulas where I'm passing in to Ptrans,
hi given hi minus 1 as i sweeps from 2 to,
um, n. Okay, so you can think about this as like a little function with local variables,
the argument to that,
um, that function r, h, and h prime.
But when I actually called this function so to speak,
when defining the joint distribution,
I'm passing in the actual variables of the Bayesian network.
Okay, any questions about this?
Okay, maybe just to summarize some concepts first.
Okay. Um, so we talked about learning
as the generically the problem of how we go from data to parameters.
And data in this case is full assignments to all the random variables.
In HMM case, it's, a data point is,
an assignment to all the hidden variables and the observed variables.
And parameters usually denoted Theta is all the local conditional distributions,
which are these, uh,
three tables in the case of HMM.
Okay. Um, the key, um,
intuition is count and normalize, um,
which is intuitive and later I'll justify why this
is an appropriate way to do parameter estimation.
Um, and then finally parameter sharing is this idea which allows you to define huge, uh,
Bayesian networks but, um,
not have to blow up the number of parameters because you can share
the parameters between the different variables, okay.
So now, let's talk about the general case.
Um, so hopefully, you kind of understand the basic intuition.
So this is just going to be, um,
some abstract notation that's gonna kind of sum it up, um.
So in a general Bayesian network,
we have variables x_1 through xn.
And we're gonna say that parameters are a collection of distributions.
So Theta equals P_d, okay.
And so big D is going to be,
um, the set of types of distributions.
So in the HMM case,
it's going to be three types: start, trans, and emit.
So basically, that's the number of the- these little boxes that I have on the board there.
Um, and the joint distribution when you define a Bayesian network is
going to be the product of P of X_i given x parents of i.
So this is the same as we had before.
But now notice the crucial difference which I've out-
outlined in red here is that I'm subscripting this p with,
um, a d_i, okay.
So what d_i for the i'th variable says is
which of these distributions is powering that variable, okay?
So d of, uh,
this variable is emit,
d of this variable is, uh,
transition, and d of this variable is start, okay.
So this looks maybe a little bit abstract, um, um, notationally,
but the idea is just to multiply in the probability is,
uh, that, uh, was used to generate that variable or power that variable.
Okay. And parameter sharing just means that the d_i could be the
same for multiple i's. Yep?
In a Markov model case where the emission probabilities are all the same for all variables.
Like why do we need multiple emission distributions,
like, wouldn't be the same as just drawing a emission distribution different?
Yes, so the question is if we only have one emission, uh,
distribution, why do we need so many of these replica copies?
Um, and the reason is that,
these variables represent, um,
the objects' locations at a particular time.
So the value of this is gonna be different based on what time step you're at.
But the mechanism for generating that variable is the same.
Just like if I flipped,
a coin, you know, 10 times,
I only have one distribution that represents the probability of heads,
but I have 10 realizations of that random variable.
Um, another analogy that might be helpful is think of probability of these as,
like, a parameter- of, like,
functions in your program that you can call, right.
This is like a sorting function.
And sorting is just used in a whole bunch of different places,
but it's kind of the same- kind of local function that, uh,
powers a bunch of, uh, different, um,
use cases which are specific to the context.
Yeah. Okay, so in this general notation,
what does learning look like?
So the training data is, um,
a set of full assignments and I want to output the parameters.
So here's the, the basic form,
it's count and normalize.
So in counting, um,
there's just a bunch of for loops.
So for each, um, training example,
which is x is a full assignment,
I'm gonna look at every, um, variable.
I'm going to just increment a counter which,
uh, of the di'th, um, uh,
distribution of this particular configuration, uh,
x parents i and xi, okay.
And then in the normalization step,
I'm going to consider all the different types of, um, distributions.
And then I'm gonna consider all the possible local assignments to the parents,
and I'm going to normalize,
um, that distribution. Yeah?
[inaudible] of d_i the right table we're looking, correct?
Yeah, so the d_i, uh, refers for the i'th variable,
which red table I'm looking at.
[NOISE].
Okay. So, um, I've given you already a bunch of examples.
So hopefully this, um,
the notation might be a little bit abstruse,
but hopefully you guys already have the, you know, intuition.
Um, any questions? We're moving on.
The main point of this slide is just to say that this is actually very general and I
just didn't do it for
hidden Markov models and naive Bayesian doesn't work for anything else.
Okay. So now let me come back to the question of,
you know, why does count and normalize make sense, right?
So count and normalize is just like,
you know, some made up procedure.
So why is it a reasonable thing to do?
And it turns out this is actually based on very firm kind of foundational principles,
this idea of maximum likelihood,
which is an idea from statistics,
um, that says if I see some data and I have,
uh, a model over that data,
I want to tweak the parameters to make
the probability of that data as high as possible, okay?
Uh, so in symbols,
what this looks like is I want to find the parameters Theta.
So remember parameters are probabilities in the,
uh, red tables on the board, um,
and then I'm going look at- make the product of all
over all the training examples the probability of that assignment.
So for every possible setting of the parameters,
I can, that assigns particular probabilities to, um,
my training examples and I want to make that number as high as possible, okay?
And the point is that the algorithm on the previous slide exactly
computes this maximum likelihood through,
uh, parameters in closed form,
so which is really nice.
If you think about when we talk about machine learning,
we define a loss function and you cannot
compute anything in closed form except for maybe linear regression,
and you have to use stochastic gradient descent to optimize it.
Here, it's actually much simpler because of the way that the model is setup.
You just count and normalize,
and that is actually,
uh, the optimal answer.
So just because you write down a max,
it doesn't always mean you have to use gradient descent.
Is the, is the lesson here. Um, okay.
So let me- I'm not gonna prove this in generality,
but I want to give you some intuition why, uh,
this is true and hopefully connect the,
the kind of the,
the abstract principle with, uh,
on the ground, um,
algorithm that you- of count and normalize.
So suppose we have, um, uh,
two variable Bayesian network with genre and rating.
So I have three data points here and I have this maximum likelihood principle,
which I'm, you know,
going to follow and let's do some algebra here.
So I'm gonna expand the joint distribution,
and remember joint distribution is just the product
of all the local conditional distributions,
um, and I've also expanded this,
you know, the product over these three instances.
So I have the probability of d,
probably of 4 given d, um,
probability of d here,
probably of 5 given d, um,
probably of c, and probably of 5 given c, okay?
And what I'm maximizing over here right now
is a distribution over genre and I have a distribution of
rating conditioned on genres c and the distribution of rating conditions
genre equals d. Okay.
So, um, I've color-coded these in a certain way to emphasize, um,
that the- all the red touches is,
is the local conditional distribution correspond to genre,
the blue is corresponds to, um,
probability of rating given genre equals d and green
is probability of rating given genre equals c, okay?
So now I can shuffle things around, okay?
And I notice, um,
that these factors don't actually depend on probability of g at all.
So they can just hang out over here.
And I've essent- and the- and this likewise, um,
if I'm thinking about the maximum over,
uh, you know, argument c,
these other factors are just constants.
So they don't really matter either.
So I've basically reduced this as a problem of three independent maximization problems, okay?
And this is why I could take each local conditional distribution in turn
and do count and normalize on each one separately. Um, okay.
And then the rest is actually, um, you know,
to do- to do do it actually properly,
you have to use Lagrange multipliers,
um, to, to solve it.
But, um, intuitively, uh,
hopefully you can either do that or just believe that if I ask you,
um, what is the probability,
best way to set probabilities so that this quantity is maximized,
I'm going to set, um,
probability of d equals two-thirds and probability of c equals one-third.
[NOISE] This is similar to one of the questions on,
uh, the foundations homework if you, uh,
remember, but only for probability of,
um, uh, a coin flip essentially.
Okay. So hopefully some of you can now,
uh, rest, uh, you know,
sleep at night thinking that if you do count and normalize,
you're actually obeying some,
um, high-minded principle of maximum likelihood.
Okay. Um, so let's talk about Laplace smoothing.
So here's a scenario.
If I have given you a coin and I said I don't know what's the probability of heads,
but you flip it 100 times and 23 times it's heads and 77 times it's tails.
What is the maximum likelihood,
uh, estimate going to be?
Yeah. So it's going to be probability of heads is,
you know, count and normalize, uh,
it's 23 over 100, which is 0.23,
probability of tails is 0.77, okay?
So it seems reasonable, right?
Um, so what about this?
So you flip a coin once and you get heads,
what's the probability of heads?
So the maximum likelihood says 1 and 0.
So, you know, some of you are probably thinking, you know,
smiling and you're probably thinking,
"This is a very, uh,
closed-minded thing to do, right?"
Just because you saw one heads, it's like, "Oh, okay.
The probability of heads must be 1.
Tails is impossible because I never saw it."
So it seems pretty, um,
you know, foolish, um,
and intuitively you feel like, "Well,
tails might happen, you know, sometimes.
Um, so it shouldn't be as stark as 1, 0."
Okay. And this is an example of overfitting,
which we talked about in the machine learning lecture,
where maximum likelihood will tend to just maximize the probability,
and in here it does maximize the probability
because the probability of data is now 1 and you can't do better than that.
But this is definitely overfitting.
So we want, uh,
a more reasonable estimate.
So this is where Laplace smoothing comes in,
and again I'm gonna introduce Laplace smoothing, uh,
from kind of a follow your nose kind of framework and then,
um, I'll talk about why it might be a good idea.
Okay. So here's maximum likelihood, um,
just the number of times heads occurs over the total number of trials you have.
So Laplace smoothing is, um,
just adding some numbers.
Um, so, uh, La- this is Laplace named after the famous French mathematician who,
um, did a lot more than add numbers, um,
like the Laplace transform and Laplace distribution.
But we're only going to use or talk about his, um,
adding numbers, um, invention I guess.
Um, so, so here in red,
I'm shown that for this probab- estimate,
no matter what the data is,
I'm just gonna add a 1 here.
I don't care what the data looks.
I'm just gonna add a 1 and we're gonna divide by the total number of values,
uh, which are possible, which is 2, heads or tails.
And for tails, I'm also gonna add a 1,
I don't care what the data says, um,
and I'm gonna divide by 2, okay?
So now I get two-thirds and one-third,
which should be a more,
you know, sensib- intuitively sensible
estimate if you're gonna come up with any sort of estimate.
It says, "Well, I saw heads,
so probably more than 50% is gonna be heads.
But, um, it's probably not, you know, 100%."
Um, okay.
So let's look at it in a slightly,
uh, more complicated setting.
So here I have two variables and, um,
Laplace smoothing is driven by a parameter Lambda, um,
which by default is going to be 1,
but it can be any number,
um, uh, non-negative number.
Um, and what Laplace smoothing amounts to is
saying start out with your tables and instead of filling them up with 0,
fill them in with Lambda, okay?
So here's my table. Before I even look at the data,
I'm just gonna put 1s down.
And then when I look at my data,
I'm just going to add to that counter.
So d shows up twice,
c shows up once,
and then count and normalize,
okay? Same over here.
Before I look at any data,
I'm just gonna populate with ones, which is Lambda,
and then I get my three data points and I add the three counters,
uh, which are shown here,
and I count and normalize.
So by construction, no,
uh, events should have probability of 0 unless Lambda is 0.
Because I already start with 1,
and 1 divided by some positive number is not 0, okay?
So the general idea is, uh,
for every distribution and partial assignment, um,
I'm going to add Lambda to that count, um, you know,
and then I'm just going to normalize,
uh, to get the probability estimates, okay?
So an interpretation of Laplace smoothing is you're essentially, you know, um,
pretending that you saw Lambda occurrences of
every local assignment even though you didn't see in your data.
You're hallucinating this, this data,
sometimes it's called pseudocounts or virtual counts.
Um, and the more, uh,
higher Lambda is, the more hallucination or more smoothing you're doing,
and that will draw the probabilities closer to the uniform, you know,
distribution and the other extreme Lambda equals 0 is simply maximum likelihood.
But in the end, you know,
data, uh, wins out.
So if you had, um,
Laplace smoothing and you saw one head and,
uh, now you're saying estimated the probability of two-thirds.
But suppose you keep on flipping this coin and it keeps on coming up heads 998 times,
then by doing the same Laplace smoothing,
you're going to eventually update your probability to 0.999.
You're never gonna reach 1 exactly because no probabilities are going to be ever 0 or 1.
But increasingly, you're gonna be much
more confident that this is a very, very rich coin.
Okay. Any questions about Laplace smoothing?
[NOISE]
So Laplace smoothing is [NOISE] just,
um, add Lambda to everything essentially.
And oh, so, so I forgot the principle behind Laplace
smoothing is if you think in terms of,
um, this is, kind of,
beyond the scope of this course but you can think about
a prior distribution over your parameters,
um, which is, um, some uniform distribution.
And, um, instead of doing maximum likelihood,
you're doing, um, map or a mac- maximum a posteriori estimation.
So there is another principle but you don't have to worry about it for this class. Yeah?
[inaudible] make Lambda?
The question is how big you make Lambda?
Um, it's a good question so one is- Lambda should be small.
It probably shouldn't be like 100.
Um, probably should be more like 1 or even- you can make it less than 1,
maybe it should be like 0.01 or something.
It depends on, um, you know,
how, I guess, uncertain, you know, you are.
So in general, that these priors are meant to capture what you know about the,
um, the, kind of, the distribution at hand.
Okay. All right.
So now we get to the fun part, this is going to- in some sense,
combined learning which we'd done with probabilistic inference,
uh, which we did before.
And the motivation here is that,
what happens if you don't observe some of the variables?
So far, learning has assumed that we
observe complete assignments to all the random variables,
but in practice, this is just not true, right?
The whole reason people call them Hidden Markov models is that
you don't actually observe the, the hidden states.
So what happens if we only get the observations?
Or the simpler example,
what happens if the data looks like this where we
observe the ratings but we don't observe the genres?
So what can you do?
So obviously, the counter normalized thing doesn't work
anymore because you can't count with question marks.
So, um, there is,
again, two ways to think about what to do here.
The high-minded principle is appeal to
maximum likelihood and make it work for, uh, unobserved variables.
Um, and the other way to think about it which I'll come to later
is simply guess what the latent variables are and then do counter normalize.
Okay? And those- these two are gonna be equivalent.
So let's be high-minded for now and think about,
um, what maximum marginal likelihood.
Okay? So in general,
we're going to think about H as the hidden variables and E as observed variables.
In this case, G is hidden,
and R1 and R2 are observed.
And suppose I see some evidence E,
so I see R_1 equals 1 and R_2 equals 2 but I don't see the value of G. And again,
the parameters are all the same, the same as before.
I just have less data or information to estimate the parameters.
Okay. So if you're following maximum likelihood,
what does maximum likelihood say?
It says tweak the parameters so that the likelihood of your data is as large as possible.
So what is the likelihood of the data here?
It's simply instead of H and E,
I have probability of E. Okay?
So this seems like a, kind of,
a very natural sound extension of maximum likelihood,
um, and it's called, um, maximum marginal likelihood.
[NOISE] Um, because, um,
this [NOISE] quantity is a marginal likelihood, right?
It's not a joint likelihood or a joint distribution, it's
a marginal distribution over only a subset of the variables.
Okay. So now, to unpack this a bit,
um, [NOISE] what is this marginal distribution?
It's actually, uh, by the axioms of probability,
it's the summation over
all possible values of the hidden variables of the joint distribution.
So in other words, you can think about maximum marginal likelihood as saying I
wanna change the parameters in such a way that such that, um,
the probability of, um,
what I see as high as possible,
but what that really requires me to do is think about all the possible values that,
um, H could take on.
I don't see it, so I have to consider what if's,
what if it were C?
What if it were D and so on?
Okay? So in other words, fundamentally,
if you don't observe a variable,
you have to consider possible values on it.
All right. So now, let's, uh,
skip to the other side of the,
kind of, scrappy way and think about what is a reasonable algorithm that makes sense.
And I'm not gonna have time, uh,
in this course to, kind of,
show the formal connection,
but if you take, you know, CS 228 or a graphical models class,
um, you'll go into this in much more detail.
Um, so the intuition here is, um,
the same as what we had for k-means.
So remember in k-means,
you tried to do clustering,
you don't know the,
the centroids, and you also don't know the assignments.
So it's a chicken and egg problem.
So you go back and forth between, uh,
figuring out what the centroids are and figuring out what the, the assignments are.
And the centroids are going to be an analog of parameters here,
and the assignments are going to be the analog of the hidden variables.
Okay? So here's, here's the algorithm.
Um, it's called Expectation-Maximization.
It was, you know, formalized, um,
in its generality in the- in the 70's,
and you start out with some parameters,
um, maybe initializing to uniform or uniform plus a little bit of, uh, noise.
And then it's gonna alter- we're gonna alternate
between two steps: the E-step and the M-step.
Um, and if you- it's useful to think about
the k-means in your head while you're going through this algorithm.
So, um, in the E-step,
we're going to guess what
the hidden variables are or what the values of the hidden variables take on.
So we're going to define this q of h which is going to be,
uh, or represent our guess.
And since we're in probability land,
we're going to consider the distribution over, uh,
possible values of h. And this guess is going to be given
by our current setting of parameters,
and the, the evidence that we've observed in our fixing.
So we're asking the question what is the probability
of the hidden variables taking on particular values of h,
given my data and given my parameters?
So this should- this should look, kind of,
familiar to you, right?
What is this? This is just probabilistic inference, right?
Which we've been doing for,
um, the last lecture.
Which means that, you can use any probabilistic inference algorithm here,
you can do forward backward,
you can do Gibbs sampling,
um, and that's, kind of,
some module that you need to do, um, EM.
Okay? Okay so now what happens if we have our,
uh, setting of- or guess over the possible values H?
Now, we, um, make up data.
Um, so we create weighted points, um,
of- with particular values of H and E, and, um,
each of them gets some weight, uh,
q of h. Um, and then finally,
once we're given these weighted points,
now we're just going to use,
uh, do counter normalize and do maximum likelihood.
[NOISE] Okay?
So I'm gonna walk through an example,
um, to make this a little bit more grounded out.
Um, so I'm gonna do this on a board because it's [NOISE] gonna get a little bit,
um, maybe a little bit hairy.
Um, okay.
Let's, let's do this.
So here, we have a three variable, uh, Bayesian network.
So we have- um,
let's draw it over here.
Actually, I might need a space.
So we have G, we have R_1 and [NOISE] R_2.
Okay? And our data that we see is, ah,
we get [NOISE] data which is,
um, 2, 2 and 1, 2.
Okay? So I observed, um, 2, 2,
that's one data point and,
uh, 1, 2, that's another data point.
Okay? Um, so initially,
what I'm going to do is,
um, start with some setting of parameters.
Okay? So I'm going to start with my parameters Theta,
[NOISE] which specify a distribution over,
uh, g. And for,
[NOISE] um, lack of information [NOISE] I'm going to consider [NOISE] just half and half.
Let me write 0.5 to be consistent.
[NOISE] So I'm initializing it with a uniform distribution,
and my other table here is going to be, um,
g and r. So [NOISE] probability of, um,
[NOISE] uh, r given g. [NOISE] And here,
I have c, [NOISE] uh,
the possible values of g and the possible [NOISE] values of r
which for simplicity I'm gonna assume to just be 1 and 2.
Um, and then for this,
I have- [NOISE] for these numbers, 0.4,
0.6, um, [NOISE] and 0.6, 0.4.
So I'm- [NOISE] I'm not setting them to uniform,
um, but adding a little bit of noise.
So hopefully, people can check that,
um, the numbers on the board are the same as the numbers on the slides.
Okay. So- [NOISE] so that's my initial parameter setting.
So now, in the E step,
[NOISE] I'm gonna use these parameters and to guess what g is.
[NOISE] Okay? So what does this look like?
Um, so [NOISE] for [NOISE] each possible datapoint.
So for every example,
so I have 2, 2, that's one datapoint.
I'm gonna try to guess what the value of g is.
So it could be c, [NOISE] um,
it could be d. And for the other datapoint: 1,
2, [NOISE] it also could be c or it could be d. Okay?
[NOISE] And now, I'm gonna try to,
um, compute a weight for each of these datapoints [NOISE] based on the model.
Okay? So the weight is- not now,
look- look at this. This is cool, right?
Because I have a fu- a complete
assignment and you know what to do with complete assignments.
I can just evaluate the probability of that assignment.
Okay? So now, um,
ju- just to make things concrete,
I have probability of g times [NOISE] probability of r_1 given
g [NOISE] probability of r_2 given g. [NOISE] Um,
this is by definition the probability of g [NOISE],
um, 2 equals, uh [NOISE].
Sorry, that's a little bit messy but-
[NOISE] So this is joint distribution by definition of this Bayesian network, it's this.
Um, okay?
So how do I compute the probability of this configuration?
Well, it's a probability of g equals c. So I look at this table.
That can be a 0.5 [NOISE] times the probability of r_1 given g, that's,
uh, 2 and c. So if we look over here, that's, ah, 0.6.
[NOISE] And then another r_2 given g,
that's also a 2 and a c. So [NOISE] that's,
ah, 0.6 because of parameter sharing.
[NOISE] And that's, ah, 0.18, right?
[NOISE] Um, let me give you guys a slide so you guys can check my work. Um, Okay.
So now, I look at this table.
So probability of g equals d is 0.5.
[NOISE] Um, and then the probability of r_1 equals 2 given g
equals d. Or if we look in this table [NOISE], that's 0.4.
[NOISE] And then I have another 0.4 from the other two,
and that is [NOISE] 0.08.
Um, and then I can normalize this. Question?
[NOISE] [inaudible] versus 0.6 for c2?
So why is this 0.4 versus, uh, 0.6 here?
Um, this is because I initialize the parameters so
that the probability of r equals 2 givens g equals d is 0.4.
So I- I guess I'm wondering why did you use that initialization?
Ah, why did I use this initialization?
Um, just for fun. I just made it up.
[LAUGHTER] Just so that if I had put 0.5's here,
then you couldn't tell what was going on.
And also, um, as a side mark it wouldn't,
um, you know, work, ah, yeah. [NOISE].
So initialization is always random?
Initialization is generally going to be
random but as close to uniform as, as possible. Yeah.
Thank you.
Okay. So this is- this column is going to be the probability of, um,
basically G equals [NOISE] g,
uh, r- R_1 equals R_1,
R_2 equals R_2 [NOISE].
Okay? [NOISE] And then the q, um,
is going to just be [NOISE],
um, is just going to be the weight of this.
And normalizing these two,
which means that you add them up and you divide,
[NOISE] and then you get, uh,
was it 0.69 and 0.31?
[NOISE] Sorry, the numbers are a little bit kind of,
um, awkward but that's what you get there.
Ah, I'm not gonna do the second row but it's,
it's basically the same type of calculation. Question?
[inaudible] kind of like particle filtering in that like in [NOISE] each step,
you do like the proposal and then then waiting,
and then the end step is like you're res- resampling, like finding the maximum?
Um, so the question [NOISE] is,
is you use, um,
Expectation-Maximization is [NOISE] kind of like
particle filtering because you have this proposal and you're reweighting.
Um, structurally, it's quite different.
I mean, there is a sense like there's some,
um, you're proposing different options.
But certainly, the two algorithms are meant to solve very different tasks.
One is for learning and one is for, um, probabilistic inference.
Yeah. Okay. So let's look at the M-step now.
Okay. So the M-step.
Uh, I'll let you guys fill this in.
So the M-step- [NOISE] um,
I actually wanna keep this up.
[NOISE] Let me do the M-step over here.
[NOISE] Is going to- now,
just take, ah, these examples.
[NOISE] So these weights are 0.5.
So it's, it's like someone handed you fully labeled data.
Complete observations, four points but each of observation has a weight.
So now, the only difference when counter normalized.
Instead of just adding 1 whenever you see a particular configuration,
you are gonna add the weight.
Okay. So [NOISE] for each of the parameters,
I'm going to look at,
um, so this is gonna be [NOISE], uh,
g probability of g. [NOISE] So this can be either c or d. Um,
[NOISE] and to get this I have- let me first do the count I guess.
Well, okay, let me just add it here.
So I look at my data.
[NOISE] So let me mark this.
So this is now my kind of, um,
I'm gonna put data in quotes because I didn't actually observe it,
I just hallucinated It.
And these are the weights [NOISE] which are associated with the data points.
So now, I'm going to look at g- uh,
look at g equals c. So I see c here,
c here, and I have,
um, the weights 0.69,
um, [NOISE] 0.69 plus
0.5 probability of- sorry, I just count.
[NOISE] And then for d. I see a d here and I see a d here.
That's 0.31 [NOISE] plus 0.5.
[NOISE] And then I normalize this and I get my estimate.
Okay. So on the slide,
this is exactly what I did here.
I count and normalize.
And I'm gonna- not gonna do this table, um, but you,
hopefully get the idea. Yeah.
[inaudible] [NOISE] estimate for all possible assignments of h?
Yeah. So in each step,
you have to estimate for all possible assignments to h. So in this case,
h is only one variable.
Um, in the next example,
h is going to be in a hidden Markov model,
all the variables, and we're gonna see how we can deal with that. Yeah?
Can you explain briefly how we get the values in the second table?
[NOISE] The second table with this one?
[inaudible].
This one?
Yes.
Yeah. Sure. Just, uh,
briefly- so you look at these datapoints,
um, and you see, ah, c1.
Okay. So where does c1 show up?
So g equals c here,
r_1 equals 1 here,
so that's a 0.5 here.
And then what about c2?
Where does c2 show up?
c2 shows up twice here with r1 and r2.
So that's why there's two of, ah, 0.69's here.
And, uh, c2 shows up once here with a weight of 0.5.
So everything in the [inaudible].
Yeah. Everything here- these counts are based on the table from,
ah, the a step there.  [NOISE].
Okay? All right.
So let's do something a little bit fun now.
[NOISE] Um, so the Copiale cipher is
this 105 page encrypted volume that
was discovered and people date it back from the 1730s.
So it looks like this.
So it's unreadable because it's actually a cipher,
it's not meant to be just read.
Um, and for decades,
people were trying to figure out, you know,
what is the actual, uh,
message that was inside this text. It's a lot of text.
Um, and, and finally in 2011, um, some researchers,
um, actually cracked this code [NOISE] and they actually used,
um, EM to help do this.
So I'm gonna give you a kind of a toy version of using EM to do decipherment.
And it turns out that this code is, um, uh,
basically some book from a secret society,
which you can go read about on Wikipedia if you want.
Um, so substitution ciphers.
A substitution cipher consists of a substitution table which specifies for every letter,
assume we have only 26 right now, um,
a cipher letter, okay?
And the way you apply a substitution table is you take
a plaintext which generally is unknown,
if you're trying to decipher like, you know,
let's say hello world and you look up each letter
in the substitution table and you write down the corresponding thing.
So h maps to n. So you write n,
e maps to m,
so you write down m and so on.
And so someone did this and then they obviously didn't give you the plaintext.
They give you the ciphertext.
And so now all you have is a ciphertext.
And obviously, he didn't give you the substitution table either.
So you- all you have is the ciphertext and you're trying to figure out both the cipher,
a, a substitution table,
and also the plaintext, okay?
So hopefully this, uh, pattern matches something.
And let's try to model this as a Hidden Markov Model, okay?
So here, the hidden variables are going to be the characters in the plaintext.
This is the actual sequence that the hello world.
And then observations are the characters of the ciphertext.
So familiar equation, the joint distribution
of the Hidden Markov Model is given by this equation,
and we want to estimate the parameters which include p_start, p_trans, and p_emit.
Okay. So how do we go about, um, doing this?
So we're gonna approach this in a, um,
in a slightly different way,
I guess, than, uh,
simply just running the algorithm because we have,
um, additional structure here, right?
So the probability of start,
I've no idea, So we just set it to uniform.
The, the probability of transition.
So this is interesting.
So normally if you're doing EM,
you don't know the probability of transition.
But because we know- let's say we know that,
uh, the underlying text was English,
we can actually estimate the probability of a wo- of
a character given a previous English character from just English text lying around.
So this is cool because it allows us to hopefully simplify the problem.
Um, I, I should maybe comment that in general,
unsupervised learning is really, really hard.
And just because you can write down a bunch of equations doesn't mean that will work.
And, and, and it's very hard to get it to work.
So you want to get as much, um,
kind of supervision or,
uh, information as you can.
Okay. So finally, e- p_emit
is the substitution table which we're gonna derive from EM, okay?
So now the, the- this might not type check in your head because a substitution
specifies for every letter, one other letter,
the cipher letter, but in order to fit into this framework,
we're going to think about,
uh, a distribution over possible cipher,
uh, letters given a plaintext letter, okay?
With the intention that well,
you know, if it's doing its job, it can always, uh,
put a probability 1 on the actual cipher letter, okay?
So just, you know,
stepping back away from the formulas, um,
why might you think this could work?
And in general, this is not obvious that it should work.
But, but what, what you have here is, um, a,
a language model p_transition,
which tells you kind of what plain text looks like, right?
If you gen- generated a cipher and you say, ah,
this is my cipher and you get some garbage,
then it's probably not right.
So we have some information about what we're looking for.
Like, so like when you solve a puzzle,
you know when you kind of solved it.
Um, and then finally we also have this emission that tells us that each,
uh, letter that E has to go to kind of be substituted in the same way.
So you can't have E going to, you know,
different- completely different things at different, uh, points at a time.
Okay. So, um, so for doing estimation in HMM,
we're going to use the EM algorithm.
And remember, in the E-step,
we're just doing probabilistic inference.
And we saw that forward backward gives us probabilistic inference.
In particular, it gives you- for every, um, position,
I'm going to give you, uh,
my guess which is a distribution of,
uh, possible hidden variables.
So remember at each position,
I observed a cipher letter,
and I'm going to guess a distribution over the plain text letter, okay?
And then the M-step,
I'm just going to count and normalize as we did before.
So once I've guessed the cipher letters,
I can just, um,
compute the probability of some cipher letter given a plain text letter, okay?
So I'm actually going to code this up, um,
and see, um, it in- so you can see it in action.
Okay. I only have five minutes here.
So- to make this quick.
Um, okay. So here we have ciphertext, okay?
Looks pretty good. Um, we're gonna decrypt this or, or decipher it.
[NOISE] Um, and then we also have our, uh,
text, uh, which is just, uh,
some English text that we, uh, found.
Um, and then I'm going to- whoops,
I wanna decipher and not encipher.
Okay. Um, so there's some utilities which are gonna be useful.
So things for reading text,
converting them to things- into integers, um,
normalization of, uh, weight,
and then most importantly the s- implementation of
a forward-backward algorithm which we're gonna use.
Um, [NOISE] okay, because I'm not gonna try to do that in five minutes.
[NOISE] Um, okay.
So let's initialize the HMM.
And then later, we're gonna run EM on it, okay?
So the HMM parameters are- there's gonna be start,
um, probability which is p in our notation, probability of start,
and this is going to be one over the number of possible,
uh, letters here, [NOISE] Um,
for this is just of- a uniform distribution,
uh, 1 over k. And I should say k is 26 plus 1.
So this is, uh, lowercase letters plus space.
[NOISE] Okay.
So now we have our, um, transition probabilities.
Um, and I'm going to- this is gonna define a distribution over, uh,
um, hidden variable, [NOISE] uh,
our next hidden variable given previous hidden variable.
And notice that the order is reversed here because I wanna first condition on each one.
And then this the- thing is gonna be a distribution.
[NOISE] Um, so to do this,
I'm going to first, um, remember my strategies.
I'm gonna use the language model data to, to count.
So I'm going to have,
um, again, set things to, uh,
0 for h_2 and range k for h_1 and range k. So this basically gives me a,
a matrix of k by k matrix of all 0s.
[NOISE] Um, and now I'm going to get my raw text, um,
and I'm gonna read it from,
um, lm.train which, remember, looks like this.
Um, and I'm gonna convert this into a sequence of integers where,
um, they're gonna be 0 to k minus 1.
Um, and then I'm going to- how do I estimate the transition?
Uh, again, counter normalize.
So I'm going to go through this sequence and, um,
[NOISE] and I'm going to count every successive transition from one character to another.
And I'm going to,
um, so I'm going to- at position I,
I have a character which is rawText of i at position i plus 1,
I have another character h_2 [NOISE] and I'm just going to increment this count.
[NOISE]
Okay? And finally I'm gonna normalize this distribution.
So, um, transitionProbs equals,
um, so for every,
um, h1, um,
I have- I have a transition counts of h1,
and I can call
the helpful normalize function which takes this distribution and normalizes it.
Okay? So this is just doing fully observed
maximum likelihood count normalized on just the,
um, the plain text.
Okay? [NOISE] Um, all right.
So now emissionProbs, um,
this is going to be probability of emits of e given h,
and I'm going to just initialize these to uniform because I don't know any better.
Um, so 1 over K
for e in range K for range K. So it just so happens that both the,
um, hidden variables and observed variables have the same domain,
um, that's not generally the case.
Okay? So now, I'm ready to run EM.
So, um, gonna do 200 iterations just- just put in a number.
Um, so have the E-step and the M-step.
So in E-step, remember I'm gonna do probabilistic inference.
I'm gonna call forward backward.
And remember this is, um,
this is going to be basically in
our notation at the position I- what is my distribution over hidden states?
So this is actually forward backward,
um, oh, I need a, um,
read some observations and read my ciphertext, uh,
ciphertext, and I'm going to convert this again into an integer array.
Um, and then I have observations,
and then I pass in the parameters of my,
um, hidden Markov model,
um, and then, I have my guess.
So let me print out what that guess is.
Okay? So what I'm gonna do here is for every position,
I'm going to get the most, uh,
likely outcome of h. So util of argmax of q i,
um, for i in range,
um, length of observations.
Okay? So that gives me an array of guesses for each position, um,
and then I'm gonna convert that into a string so it's easier
to look at, and put them in line.
[NOISE] So this is printing on the best guess.
Okay. So finally for the M-step, um,
I'm go- I have my,
uh, q which gives me counts.
So now I pretend I have a lot of,
you know, data which are weighted by q.
So I'm gonna have emission,
um, counts equals, uh, same as before.
I'm just gonna get a matrix of 0s, um,
e in range K for h in range K,
um, and then I'm gonna go through the sequence,
from i equals range of through the length of the observation sequence,
um, and for each, uh,
position in the sequence,
I'm gonna consider all the possible,
um, possible plaintext hidden values,
[NOISE] and I'm going to increment, um,
h, observations of i,
so this is the observation that I actually saw.
Um, and this should be qih which is the weight of,
uh, eight h at position i.
Okay? And then finally I'm just going to normalize.
So, um, like what I did,
uh, well, okay I'll just normalize it here.
So emission probabilities is util dot, um,
normalize of the accounts, um,
for h in range K. Okay?
And I think that's, uh, pretty much it.
Um, lemme me see if this- okay.
Um, this should be [NOISE]
for for e but- right?
Okay. Okay. Good. Um, okay.
So let's ru- run this and then I'll go back to
the- lemme just go over that code just one more time.
Okay. So, [LAUGHTER] uh,
we initialize the, the probabilities, to uniform.
For transition probabilities we can use our observations,
uh, or the- just a plaintext.
We just count and normalize.
In emissions, um, we initialize with uniform,
and then while running EM,
we read the ciphertext,
and then in the E-step,
we're going to use the current prob- parameters to guess where the ciphertext is.
And then we're going to update our estimate of what
the parameters are given our guess of what the ciphertext is.
Okay. So here's the final moment of truth.
Uh, the ciphertext- and so
remember each iteration it's going to print out the best guess.
So hope, it'll look like gibberish for a little bit.
It's not gonna be perfect, um,
but this is- it starts to look somewhat like English.
Um, there's an and, and in my in there,
um, anyone can read this?
[BACKGROUND] Alone without- okay,
that looks like English.
Can be this like anyone that I could.
Anyone to guess what this text is?
So here's the plain text.
So I've lived my life alone without anyone that I could
really talk to until I had an accident with my plane and the,
um, does with my- whatever something.
[LAUGHTER] But so, again,
unsupervised learning doesn't- it's not magic.
It doesn't always work, but here you at least
see some signal, and in the actual application,
they got partway there and then,
you can iterate on this man- kind of in a manual way.
[BACKGROUND] Okay.
[BACKGROUND] Oops.
All right. So that's for it for Bayesian networks.
On Wednesday we'll do [NOISE] logic.